salut internet cette semaine j'ai décidé
de vous parler d'un casse tête parce que
c'était des gens fait pas mal sûrement
le plus beau casse tête que j'ai vu en
termes de réalisation c'est le cadenas
64 alors c'est l'un des plus durs aussi
mais il est juste très très jolie
fabriqués en allemagne avec du bois
précieux je vous raconterai tout ça dans
la vidéo parce que le temps que je
cherche je pense qu'on aura bien vient
le temps de parler
n'hésitez pas aussi à me suivre sur mon
instagram je vais faire des gros plans
et des ralentis de tous les détails de
ce casse tête là comme ça si vous voulez
en voir plus vous allez sûrement ni gtb
chez des petites vidéos en plus en ce
moment voilà ça fait plaisir bien bien
sûr mon instinct et tu verras des vidéos
que tu ne vois pas ailleurs
bon le principe il est très clair il va
falloir l'ouvrir je sais pas encore s'il
ya un principe de combinaisons ou pas on
va voir ça tout ça ensemble
et tant que j'y suis aussi à ce moment
là je vous rappelle que le spectacle
singularité mon troisième spectacle et à
l'olympia le 22 septembre que la salle
est presque plein on est à plus de 80 %
de remplissage donc si vous voulez venir
je pense que même si on est l'été il est
temps de penser à venir en fait dans ces
cas là voici le cadenas 64
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure je
pense que c'est l'un des plus beaux
cadenas que j'ai jamais vu en terme de
finition en termes de travail de finesse
ces faits en bois de padoue qu en pas
donc je ne sais pas quelle boîte bas
d'août si vous savez vous me dites qu'il
botte pas double dans les commentaires
et en érable et ça a été fait par deux
co auteurs en allemagne ont apprécié du
travail artisanal comme d'hab
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire je peux
vous dire que c'est magnifique
déjà je vous le fais bien voir
l'objectif il est très clair c'est qu'il
faut ouvrir le cadenas il faut le
libérer comme ça et il ya une dernière
indication qui était mis dans la notice
qui est que ça utilise un système à
l'intérieur mécanique de résolution de
cadenas qui n'a jamais été fait à ce
jour donc dans un premier temps comme
d'hab exploration je vais chercher ce
qui bouge je pense pas qu'ils et système
d'aimants autre chose comme ça ou
peut-être que je me trompe et je le
serai plus tard ces mondes possibles ça
c'est complètement lâche ça sert à rien
ça tourne dans le vide
ici on a le cadran qui tourne donc de
zéro il ya une vraie buté et dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
jusqu'à 42
environ derrière on a des trucs avec les
vis ça je pense que c'est clairement
pour la décoration serait tellement
drôle en forçant juste un petit peu sur
marne
bon ben voilà c'est ouvert là on a une
gravure numéro 00 64 points 0 0
alors je pense pas que ce soit un numéro
de série ou alors c'est un pur hasard
parce qu'ils s'appellent le cadenas 64
j'espère qu'il va 64 étape non plus
c'est peut-être la première fois que je
fais un cadenas ou du moins un casse
tête que j'arrive pas à résoudre dans la
vidéo parce que là on est sûr d'une
difficulté extrême 1 sur celui-là il ya
marqué security corp
il ya deux points noirs de chaque côté
mais ça c'est la pyrogravure et 1871 qui
peut être un indice aussi d'air il
faudrait voir si je peux faire 1 8 7 un
mois si c'est ça la difficulté extrême
laisse tomber dans un premier temps
comme d'habitude avec les castes et on
va faire la phase d'exploration du 4 et
de voir ce qui est possible de faire ou
pas donc ça on a vu que sa tournée ça
s'est tournée pour rien ça bah forcément
que c'était dérouillée excès liés à ça
parce que quand jean mougin l'autre y
bouge on voit clairement que ça et ça
c'est biais et puis le dos ma foi on
oublie pour le moment là je vais faire
un petit peu comme dans les films
américains
je me transformais en espions ou en
voleur ses terres que je ne devais pas
faire de bruit et je peux tourner
lentement le cadenas pour voir si
j'entends quelque chose vous savez
j'avais déjà fait une vidéo sur le loch
picking c'est l'ouverture de serrure en
français et on va chercher des goupilles
une par une en faisant une action
mécanique forcé pour essayer d'entendre
ce qui se passe ou de voir ce qui se
passe c'est à peu près le même concept
que je vais que je veux reproduire là on
verra si ça sert
[Musique]
e
et je 42 donc là c'est assez incroyable
entre le 02 42 quand j'ai tourné à aucun
senti quelque chose donc je garde mon
principe de c'est peut-être comme une
serrure en le picking donc je vais je
vais faire une action mécanique je vais
je pense tirer essayer de le tirer et
voir si à un moment donné il ya d'écran
qui se libère ce que je me dis ça c'est
peut-être comme dans les films droite
gauche droite droite gauche
alors voilà que j'aurais vraiment été
tentés de tester le 1871 mais j'ai pas
accès aux uns ni aux 8 me au set puisque
c'est entre 0 15
c'est reparti
la a5 déjà j'ai réussi à lever un peu
plus
ainsi ce par contre ça le ramène on le
voit là ça redescend un petit peu là
j'arrive pas aller plus loin que 47
ah oui et plus je le ramène coup je me
fais coincé le doigt et pluie re rentrer
[Musique]
alors après de longues beaucoup trop
longues minutes
état des lieux premier état des lieux
quand je fais ça j'entends un truc
dedans comme une bille ou quelque chose
mais ça roule vraiment en fait entre mes
doigts vous entendez
bienvenue dans cette lutte et hôtesses
mer le deuxième truc c'est que je pense
être dans le vrai avec le système gauche
droite gauche droite je pense pas qu'ils
aient fait autre chose avec ça le vrai
problème c'est en termes d'indicé on n'a
pas grand chose sur les chiffres
possible je pense qu'il ya un indice
quelques pas et les deux choses que j'ai
c'est 1871 ici et 0,64 point 0 0 donc
numéro 0 64 point 0,02 derrière un le 8
le 7 et le 1,2 du maire j j ai pas accès
pour le moment je suis bloqué entre 0 et
40 de abc g 7 et 8 bon j'ai pas loin
mais moi quand je tourne ça je ne sens
pas d'entraîner quelque chose c'est
comme s'ils étaient tous libres tout
vide
du coup je reviens sur mon idée de
serrures je pense pas que ce soit
crantée je sais pas trop en fait que ça
entraîne à l'intérieur dans la matrice
quelle pilule choisi du neo mais la
pilule de j'aimerais bien trouver
du coup je vais essayer cette partie là
c'était 1 0 64 00 qui peut être à la
fois un indice à la fois un numéro de
série mais comme le cadenas s'appelle
cadenas 64 je me dis qu'il ya pas de
hasard et que ça c'est pour peut-être
mais signifier que c'est un indice donc
0 64 points 0 0
donc je vais faire à 0
0 6 4
non mais oui je peux pas aller aux
quatre puisque c'est le 42 qui bloque
alors autant je fais 0,64
là je suis sur les 60 g de fèves 0,64 je
me dis ça vaut le coup de voir si déjà
il se passe un truc ou pas ok là
clairement j'entends mieux la vie que
tout à l'heure
après c'était points 0 0 donc je veux
revenir sur le 0 et alors je pense que
le 0-0 signifie zéro et encore 0 donc
peut-être que je peux faire un tour
complet maintenant
[Musique]
et maintenant il faudrait revenir sur le
zéro entendant le cadran ça marche pas
mais je peux peut-être tourner le reste
est pas le cadre j'avais un casse-tête
déjà comme ça je vous le ferez voir ça
sur peut-être sur un stage vous ferai
une vidéo très courte avec ce principe
sort pour revenir aux héros je vais
garder cette partie là fixe dans mon
environnement et je vais tourner c'est
ça et c'est pas ça une bonne idée
portant
tabou si non en fait je sens que je sens
que je suis pas loin de la solution
[Musique]
ne dis pas que je protègerai mon scooter
avec mais il est plutôt sécurisé quand
même voilà faut tout faire à l'envers
maintenant parce qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas un seul symbole différent ici
j'aurais essayé la même technique parce
que des fois aussi cesser ces mécaniques
et il suffit que j'ai mal fait un truc
ou pas appuyer ses forces
je refais la mer 0 j'entends un truc
donnant donc 0,64 j'étais bien sûr le 64
je me demande si je peux aller sur 66
plutôt que 64 on l'entend bien je
conviens sur les héros je vais refaire
la même chose que j'ai faite à la savoir
garder lui fixe dans mon environnement
3d et tourner le reste pour accéder au
deuxième 0 ap hutin j'ai entendu la
bible et de ouf et de la gêne tout passé
[ __ ] je peux pas aller plus loin en
fait t'es là on était bloqués vers là et
là on est allé vers la jusque avec le
zéro genre c'était le zéro et elle à la
place du huit ou vous c'est suffisant ce
qui voudrait dire qu'on a ouvert le
cadenas on a craqué le cadenas en une
vidéo
j'ai trop content désolé si vous voyez
ma grosse tête ou mais grosse épaules on
voit rien dedans gars à la vie elle
s'est remise jeunes touchés le cadran et
j'ai entendu schluck la bise l'abysse
héros mise donc je pense que le réseau
était instantanée en fait je suis bloqué
entre 0 et 40 de là on voit rien du tout
rien à l'intérieur un mode ils ont caché
tout le système on peut pas voir comment
ils fonctionnent tout ce qu'on peut voir
c'est un tout petit bout de métal tout
en bas je me demande si c'est pas juste
le métal de de cette partie là là
c'est ce que métal de cette partie là
ici c'est peut-être juste ça on voit
rien tout se passe à l'intérieur ils ont
tous planquer les mecs et là pourquoi
j'ai un petit peu de lumière ah oui
d'accord ce qui est juste l'interstice
ok donc remise en place du canal je
pense que c'est instantané
info peut-être de 0 7 à 0
est-ce que je peux le pas et
immédiatement en fait il est bloqué il
doit y avoir aussi une action mécanique
qui fait que quand on le repousse cdh a
poussé un truc qui doit se refermer la
billy a dû se remettre en place quand
j'ai entendu le clac et là on est
bloqués entre 0,42 être kahn n'a pu
s'ouvrir
clairement il est magique un il et il
est très joli c'est encore une fois
c'est l'un des plus beaux
je pensais beaucoup plus galérer dessus
mais comme en ce moment je fais plein de
cadenas je pense que j'ai l'esprit
allait craquer avoir des indices partout
il y en a où partout où il y en a pas
d'ailleurs avec le 1871 très très beau
canal super bel objet super beau casse
tête aller le seul petit bémol pour moi
c'est que dans ce type de cadenas mais
c'est un peu comme quand je vous ferai
les boîtes c'est qu'il ya quinze sens de
résolution c'est-à-dire une fois qu'on a
ouvert le fait de le remettre
c'est facile mais des fois les cadenas
vous l'avez vu déjà dans les précédentes
vidéos
c'est un peu en deux fois c'est à dire
en galère à le défaire et en le galère
aussi à le remettre en place
là il ya vraiment qu'une seule action je
suis trop content
un de mes préférés quand tu finis un
casse tête tu as toujours un sentiment
un peu où je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué ça c'est à la fois de la joie
limites de la fierté parce que moi je
suis quand même très fier d'avoir craqué
le cadenas 64
mais en même temps hyper déçu parce que
tu peux me le plus jamais cherché en
fait comment résoudre le cas menace
c'est ça un bonbon de déductions qui
marche qu'une seule fois quoi mais il
est vraiment cool il est très joli jeu
clairement de tout ce que j'ai fait pour
l'instant ça doit être mon préféré en
termes de logique et de et de mystère
aussi parce que je sais toujours pas ce
qui est à l'intérieur faudrait que je
trouve une mini caméra pour aller là
dedans voir skier mais il est vraiment
vraiment ou bon comme toujours je vous
mets un lien dans la description si vous
voulez vous le procurer et puis un lien
vers d'autres de casse tête que j'aime
bien et n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo
comme d'habitude à vous abonner si ce
n'est pas encore fait à très bientôt
ciao